wow
thank you everybody we are entirely
humbled and honored to be here this is
one of those sort of Pinch Me moments
and I know it's especially surreal for
Kevin to return back to campus and
relive his glory days so
um uh today we really wanted to tell you
a little bit about our story The and
focus on the early days because I think
it's so easy to forget about where we
began given the day-to-day that we focus
on now
um and and you know in in our
introduction uh We've obviously had some
some tremendous success but we have a
long way to go we wanted to really focus
on uh our stories the beginning of
Eventbrite and then some observations
that we made actually years ago in 2008
around the startup environment and the
organism you need to grow to survive so
to start from the beginning
uh we did a little his and hers part of
this because this is uh really fun for
us to do together so uh my story uh
really begins way back uh in the early
days of my childhood actually I grew up
in Santa Cruz and I was a sort of Beach
Bum ballerina uh and why I tell you that
is because I actually wasn't the child
with the lemonade stand I was really
good at taking Direction and making
adjustments and pleasing people as a
ballerina and I never in a million years
imagined that I would be an entrepreneur
and that's the truth some people say
like oh I never imagined I'd be here I
really never thought I'd be an
entrepreneur that wasn't on my roadmap
for my life and I parlaida a major in
television production they actually have
that down in La uh into a career as a
television executive at MTV networks
where I was fortunate enough to cross
paths with a sort of groundbreaking
cultural phenomena one called jackass
and I was on the team that brought
jackass to the air you're welcome oh I'm
sorry
my parents were confused uh but I uh I I
then was able to join the team at FX um
and further my career and sort of great
groundbreaking content Creation with
niptuck rescue me in the shield so how
did I end up uh going from there to here
it really has to do with this guy so uh
cross paths with Kevin at a wedding of
my boss at MTV marrying his classmate
from Stanford and as you can imagine one
half of the of the church were sort of
too cool for school MTV kids the other
half were really cool Stanford kids uh
and uh and we were the product and it
was really from there on that I was able
to vicariously live through Kevin
because he was building his second
company Zoom Xoom which he'll tell you
more about and for me that was actually
the the moment in which my path
completely jumped the rails and I was
able to identify in his journey two
elements in the technology industry that
I was missing in the entertainment
industry one velocity and two
meritocracy and so uh that sort of began
the transformation in my own life to
realizing that I could actually build
something I could actually be an
entrepreneur and I'm a great operator
and so with that we uh we found an event
right in 2006 which after Kevin tells
his story I'll give you a little bit
more detail on those early days
and now we're on to the his side uh
thank you everyone so much for having me
uh for having us and you know my
background is really centered around I
um learning and I I came from a family
that was very intellectually curious
that really really valued education uh
it's why uh we're all here today and
after coming out of Stanford and after
coming getting a masters in in Oxford
and in British history George III has so
much to do now with my application
towards technology uh you know I just
followed a path of intellectual
curiosity and learning and and that was
really the pursuit so lo and behold I
ended up in Tech if we had made this the
three-hour entrepreneur lecture series I
would explain exactly how I got to
um Tech from George III uh but um lo and
behold I I ended up in tech and and
after a successful kind of quick
successful exit in the the late 90s I
very foolishly rolled all my gains into
uh some friends I knew from colleagues
from undergrad uh and another group from
UIUC University of Illinois in in that
startup turned out to be PayPal so in
fact I had this wonderful front row seat
of watching the rocket ship of PayPal
which I I'm sure many of you know the
story of how this company assembled such
talent and and really
blasted off at a time when the rest of
the world was collapsing in the tech
industry during the the collapse and
that was of course Very uh instrumental
to me I think you know being a lesson to
entrepreneurs is be keenly observational
when you see a when you see one of these
rocket ships when you see these
phenomenal teams you take notice and you
start to observe and zoom came out of
that Zoom to explain a bit more is a
international Money Transfer Company and
it's a it's a story of disruption it's a
story uh and it's been over a decade
long story of disruption of going after
a incumbent Western Union that charges
High fees to immigrants to help we're
sending money back to their families
overseas and and that's a company that
we built really on the backs of PayPal
again when you see a large opportunity
in in that is PayPal and you see the
talent of the team they opened up an API
we we built on top of that payments they
API at the time and zoom was born out of
this Eventbrite a transactional business
similar in many aspects we also started
on the back of PayPal came out of this
unusual combination of a married couple
and our third co-founder who is actually
based remotely in in Paris and and that
was Eventbrite and I'll let Julia talk
more about the founding of Eventbrite
yes I'd like to point out how crazy
Renault was to start a company with a
with a couple we weren't married at the
time we were actually engaged we'd never
been in the same room at the same time
for more than two days so we got engaged
we moved in together we started
Eventbrite and we got married in the
first six months so if that's not trial
by fire I'm not sure what is uh and then
I had a child a year later uh and uh so
for us uh you know the three of us
unsuspecting co-founders uh sort of all
uh Against All Odds I guess uh put our
heads together and really thought about
um what kind of industry we could
disrupt with technology and it wasn't
about just being disruptive it was about
the idea of democratizing an industry so
when we thought about ticketing we
thought about uh the ways in which
people could access great live
experiences and how important live
experiences just like today are
important to human connectedness we
thought about how technology would
either fuel or kill the live experience
the offline experience and our bet was
that the Advent of Technology would
actually make it easier for people to
gather offline we weren't sure how
because again this is very early social
media days Kevin was actually an
investor in one of the first social
media sites runster but we had no idea
what role online would play in these
offline Gatherings but we had a hunch
that we could build a product that would
be self-service and would effectively
enable anybody to gather others around a
common cause was a passion and interest
when we started Eventbrite we actually
started in this Warehouse in Potrero
Hill and um let me point out our office
was a phone closet in the back of the
building and I remember pushing saw
horses as and doors for desks into this
tiny little phone closet
three days after I had just packed up my
window office on the 42nd Floor of Fox
Plaza in Beverly Hills and I thought
why is Kevin so happy I mean he was
giddy his feet were barely touching the
ground and I thought and I thought I
could maybe trust that the giddiness
there was something behind that and it's
actually the
Eternal optimism that entrepreneurs have
and that was the beginning of for me of
learning how to adopt some of that
optimism and also tapping into what I'd
always kind of known about myself which
is I love to learn by doing
and so that's what we started to do we
just started building there was never a
time in the early days when we sat
around and talked about things or
pondered things or were hesitant we just
jumped right in so I was the uh
marketing customer service and finance
department I found our customers I
talked to them on a daily basis and
finance um I'm great at numbers but we
really didn't need a balance sheet
because we were not making any money Uh
Kevin was product development so I would
take our customers feedback and send it
to Kevin who would then develop our
product and Renault built the site and
we all qaed and we did that for two
years so it's just the three co-founders
for two years and we bootstrapped the
company we actually spent less than a
quarter of a million dollars in the
first two years of building Eventbrite
and getting it to a break even status
so when we think about the early days of
Eventbrite and we think about Eventbrite
as the startup going back in time
um
we think about this this talk that Kevin
gave back in 2008 I'll never forget uh
you know we had no team it was really
just us and we spoke at a university and
Kevin gave this talk about the startup
environment and what kind of organism
you need to be to survive the startup
environment and we used all these
different examples like Netflix and
PayPal and even bibo uh and when we were
looking back at these notes because this
this talk we thought was very applicable
to this to this opportunity we realized
that Eventbrite has actually grown into
a company
um that can fit a lot of these examples
So today we're going to take you through
uh this this idea of the startup
environment and sort of the three
threats or hazards you face as a startup
and then the three characteristics that
you must have to have a successful
startup organism
so the first is access to nutrients and
I'm gonna cover customers so as I
mentioned in the very beginning
um we had no customers so uh we had to
find our first sort of early adopter
group thankfully that group lived in our
backyard they were Tech bloggers uh
Gathering people with around Tech
meetups so
um like-minded people gathering for
meetups or talks or conferences
and at the same time because we had
built this self-service easily
accessible platform we had other types
of users quickly adopting the platform
like speed dating in New York does
anybody even know what speed dating is I
mean that was in 2006 this was like the
way in which people met each other so we
had we we knew right off the bat that
our customers would be wide and varied
because we were building this horizontal
platform that can meet the needs of any
type of event organizer and that was
actually part of our strategy it was a
little bit crazy but part of the part of
the strategy and so by staying close to
our customers and really building a
relationship from the beginning again I
was the customer service department I
literally was answering customer service
emails from the labor and delivery room
when we had our first child uh and that
The Story Goes they had to take the
computer away from me and everybody said
oh she's so dedicated and I said well no
I just don't want I don't want to know
what comes next
um and so you know having that Lifeline
with our customers was actually
incredibly important to us in the
beginning because not only did it give
us direct feedback on what we were
building in real time but it allowed us
to futurecast what our customers would
need as we began to grow
the second uh sort of fuel to the
organism this startup organism is is
something if we've talked about
customers as you know I I would put them
as like the high protein the most
nutritious form of it uh capital is kind
of like the sugar uh so it gets you
going uh but it doesn't last uh and and
it gives you kind of a burst of energy
but you can't survive off it on your own
and
um over the years I'd gotten pretty good
at raising Capital with zoom zoom is a
money transfer business uh was a very
Capital intensive business we were
moving money all around the world we had
massive fraud attacks we had to build
out all these areas that we hadn't
foreseen and so it felt like during
those times albeit very exciting we were
on our heels a bit raising capital and
that was a message uh to me that was a
message really that in the next in you
know in back to that that I were in we
at Eventbrite would be very Capital
efficient and be able to lean forward
and and go after Capital when we needed
it so uh as Julia mentioned we
effectively bootstrapped the company for
the first two years and that was on this
diet of customers uh the right diet and
and then
um you know it was time to raise money
and always win uh you know as As the
adage goes uh the capital is always
there when you don't need it when you
desperately need it it's not available
and the lesson here is that we built
ourselves into a position where we
didn't need the capital
this happened to be though in in uh 2000
end of 2008 2009 and the markets
collapsed and we were terrified we
didn't know what was going to happen
with the business if we expected the
downturn uh so we started to go out and
and raise venture capital and literally
everyone in the valley uh turned us down
I still run into people and they'd go oh
I remember meeting you and saying no and
um those are the best no we don't we
don't want to do a victory dance or
anything but yeah we still have a long
ways to go but uh in short
um we we were in early 2009 at a point
where you just said well let's just put
our heads down and build the business we
took on a little uh Bridge money and lo
and behold the business had taken off
and I really think that that was because
we focused around being customer-centric
those previous two years and saw the
business really blossom in in 2009
versus as most others in all these
companies that had become bloated with
with capital and reliant on Capital had
failed uh and we culminated 2009 with uh
Sequoia Capital investing uh six and a
half million dollars at the end of that
year with roll off both uh one of these
uh one of our favorite PayPal mafiosis
uh investing leading the investment and
joining the board
the third thing that we think about is
Talent so you know it was just the three
of us for the first two years and then
we we after we raised our we actually
raised an angel round to hire our first
team and that was around 15 people in
the third year of Eventbrite and that
was such a transformative time for us
because you know being three co-founders
you're doing a lot and there's a huge
opportunity to bring on talent that is
way more brilliant than yourselves uh in
many more areas than you could possibly
have imagined to focus on in the
beginning so in the beginning it was
really just about product and customers
but once we tapped into talent and were
able to bring Talent onto our team we
were able to extend ourselves Way Beyond
where we had been in the first two years
now I want to back up and say you know
in 2006 founding a company and placing
it in San Francisco was actually
contrarian I know that's kind of uh
mind-boggling now since we are battling
the real estate Wars and the talent Wars
in San Francisco but the conventional
wisdom was that you place your company
down here near Stanford uh and uh we we
felt sort of this inherent pool towards
San Francisco A to B contrarian and B to
be near
um what is crucial and what is the
lifeline to our business which are live
experiences so San Francisco being a
very culturally dense Metro uh is a
great place for us to be to be very
close to our subject matter but what we
found was that once we got started and
once we were able to access Talent who
wanted to be part of our vision who were
sold on that vision of bringing the
world together through live experiences
that was really a turning point for
Eventbrite because it became abundantly
clear to Kevin and I that we weren't
just looking to build something and flip
it or to create just the best business
model for uh for revenue's sake but
really to create an amazing company and
so the nutrient of talent is very very
very important I can't underline it more
I'll talk about it more today actually
uh but really understanding where you
can access Talent is extremely important
and we actually took a bet on San
Francisco but I think that as we as we
look at where the trends have taken us
and now how uh you know abundant the
talent is here but how Fierce the
competition is to get Talent we
understand that we were right in saying
that Talent is a crucial nutrient for
the startup organism and I I think that
the you know PayPal story is such an
interesting one because they tapped into
two lifelines for their talent Stanford
and UIUC and I think that you know when
you fall if you follow that Legacy like
Kevin has
um from conception to Now sort of
reality it's quite astounding to see
what a group of very talented people can
do both together and then you know apart
maybe you want to go through the PayPal
um story or well I think that's that's
absolutely right on uh in in that uh you
know that focus of uh Max leptin and
Peter Thiel around highest caliber
Talent early on brought uh Subs such
depth and breadth uh again from as you
know our board member rule off Botha was
CFO of PayPal at age 26 and uh when when
the company went public uh and and you
know has led Investments that you know
range from YouTube to Eventbrite to
Evernote and so on to uh you know Peter
Thiel himself to Jeremy stompelman at
Yelp Elon Musk David sacks with the
Yammer that that Talent density is just
something that in you know the in in my
observation of that team that they
really had these trusted great leaders
in each part of the company
um that you know really shows their
their strong skills uh not just what
they accomplished but pay with PayPal
and uh but what they went off and did on
their own
um again the the list of of companies
there Yelp LinkedIn with Reid Hoffman
and so on is is extraordinary and it was
inspirational it was informative that
businesses need not only competitive
advantages in terms of technology
or business practices but Talent is is
such a great competitive Advantage uh in
in the ways to bring that talent in and
gather that Talent retain it is a core
part of of thinking when you're starting
your company
and I
and as we've progressed
and sure and look and luxury you know to
only focus on Talent so actually
one-third of the founding team of
Eventbrite spends all their time
focusing on Talent that's how important
it is to us and back then we didn't have
that luxury but I think it's been a game
changer for us to be able to put the
focus that we need to put on talent to
build this very people-centric company
so we think about you know the landscape
of of any market and you know trying to
democratize a marketer disrupt a market
and obviously there are incumbents in
that market and when we went after or
thought about ticketing as a possible
opportunity for us to um you know enable
through technology or disrupt through
technology uh or simply democratize we
thought about ticketing as sort of the
last Bastion of e-commerce where it
could be categorized by three things
bad customer experience High fees
and little to no innovation
so to us that was sort of a green light
in terms of opportunity because we felt
that we could easily do the opposite of
all those three
but we could have just gone after
Ticketmaster we could have just said
we're going to disrupt Ticketmaster and
we're going to take their market share
thankfully uh we thought better of that
and had a hunch that there might be this
gap between people who were using Excel
spreadsheet email and paper checks to
run their event or collecting cash at
the door
and Beyonce and Jay-Z at ATT Park turns
out there's a huge gap and this what we
call the long tail of ticketing is
enormous it's everything you do in your
everyday life where you gain access so
think about today this could easily be
ticketed uh cooking classes yoga
seminars and obstacle races Food and
Wine Festival music event uh you know
you name it we have it
and in the beginning we didn't know how
wide this would be in terms of how many
categories we could actually see on our
platform but we let our customers take
us there and we didn't try to go deep
into one category or one geography or
one size of a van we sort of let it just
organically evolve
I would never give an entrepreneur that
advice so I think that it was very
special that this ended up working out
for us but because we went after an
underserved Market of people like you
and I who are creating
paid events we actually had this amazing
Green Field to grow into over the years
and I think what one of the more
astounding things is just how many
categories keep coming onto the platform
so much so that we see Trends before
they even happen so we see things like
obstacle races with Tough Mudder or
electronic dance music
events becoming mainstream or food and
wine events are having their day in the
sun we have food and acts wine beer
Spirits bacon huge a thousand bacon
events on the platform last year in the
U.S we love our bacon so I think that
what I'm trying to illustrate is
capturing this uh this opportunity that
wasn't
um from the get-go very attractive is
why eventbrite's here today and why
we're seeing the growth that that we're
seeing
I'm still talking extreme
uh and you do notice I'm also driving
too this is indicative of our of our
relationship
um
delay we divide and conquer that's our
secret if you've seen that we haven't
talked over one another yet uh very
important you're just letting me talk
yeah
and I also draw I also do the driving uh
so
um so Kevin kind of mentioned our our
funding story and I want to point out
that you know in terms of of the startup
environment
um one of the things I think you do
really well as an entrepreneur Kevin is
is have
um healthy paranoia and I think that
healthier productive paranoia is
incredibly important to setting yourself
up to endure extreme seasonality because
as we know things can shift quite uh
rapidly in our world and by building
Eventbrite in an efficient way because
we didn't really have much money to
spend but thinking about ways in which
we could build this Lean Startup has
actually set us up for Success Kevin
mentioned in 2008 and 2009 when we
failed at raising money we don't tell
that story often I think I like to try
to forget it uh we actually saw one of
the strongest grow both years in the
history of the company in 2009 and the
reason was people were coming in droves
to adopt the platform to generate
revenue on their own so think about
people who had
either left their corporate jobs or lost
their corporate jobs due to the
macroeconomic environment and had
discovered Eventbrite to use our
platform to teach classes based on their
skills or to gather people around common
passions and generate Revenue we saw
these do-it-yourselfers come on to
Eventbrite in 2009 as a massive Trend
and we really understood the enablement
market and were able to lean into that
opportunity so we actually had a
tremendous year in 2009 and when we went
back to the VC community at the end of
that year and showed them our plan and
what we had done it was a completely
different discussion in terms of raising
money but I think in terms of the the
sort of big picture on Extreme
seasonality you should always be
expecting the worst we see this
as somewhat of a cycle that Kavanaugh
yeah this uh this is not to scare it's
to just make you aware that you know our
startup organisms have to have to
survive in in different environments and
uh you know we can become a kind of very
hat uh very uh you know happy
um Critter uh and then all of a sudden
find ourselves in those deserts uh and
and that's when the economy switches or
swings the other direction uh in in that
is like if there's any concerns or any
um notion of what's happening today
today we're in one of these extreme
wonderful periods and and when people
ask how things are going it's wonderful
uh capital is a plenty uh there's so
many opportunities out there but things
inevitably change and it's really a
chance it's this darwinian notion again
back to the organism
um analogy or the biology analogy is
that the conditions change and and you
don't want to be a non-adaptive uh
Critter in uh during one of these
periods and yes it happens you know I
don't know seven or eight years we can't
really predict when it does if you look
up at the the kind of last
for impacts that have uh really struck
hard at technology you see over of those
fears it just periodically happens and
we talk a lot about the pendulum of
capitalism and how as a startup uh we
act during each of those periods so when
times are going really well we want to
certainly take advantage of that and we
also want to think of how we continue to
increase our efficiency and you're
starting to hear that in the market
today out there there's more tweets and
discussions of well things might be
getting a little overheated let's really
think about the money we're spending
because at some point the pendulum it
never shifts back to the center it
always swings to the extreme other
direction and that's again that that
darwinian period where survival becomes
a challenge and building an efficient
organization being able to say having
optionality that you're not just
dependent on your next 20 million dollar
Venture Capital raise that you've
planned out and then the market window
closes that dries up what do you do in
that case that is the mode of thinking
as as a startup is to have an option A B
and C and and not just the option A of
the the big financing
so we think about this startup organism
and the optimal traits that uh that a
startup should have to weather these
conditions and we think about first and
foremost this highly efficient
organization uh that that Kevin has
outlined and maybe you want to double
down on that right well so taking this
example
um highly efficient uh this this
dovetails to you know that notion of
surviving that that seasonality we had
certain we developed certain attributes
I don't I wouldn't say that they just
popped up by accident but through a lot
of iterations and tests in the early
days of Eventbrite uh we did various
things that we learned and observed from
uh that really helped us uh to Define
our business later on for example if you
uh put down a zero dollar value ticket
you can host as an organizer you can
host a free event and that was almost an
accident we didn't we didn't intend to
set out to build a free event
functionality we we went out to build
functionality that uh there was a
member non-member and member of the
press and the member of the press would
be free or uh you know we wanted to have
the option of having that free
registration type and lo and behold
people started publishing free events
and they published them in a far greater
number and percentage than than actually
the paid events and our initial
um you know we were kind of a gas like
they can't do this they're used in our
product and we're not being paid and
then we took a close look at that and
looked at the content being created
which was in its day and still is being
indexed by Google and search engines uh
the invitations the awareness that was
being raised by those using Eventbrite
as a free service and when we started to
look at this in a quantitative measure
we found that that was actually fueling
the growth of the business uh that's
that more free events free events out
there we get more organizers and in this
virtual Circle grows in fact another
area of efficiencies we we really
latched on to is this notion of what we
call a tentative organizer ATO
um which has the unfortunate same
acronyms as account takeover so please
don't confuse the two of those hackers
out there but there are ATO rate was
that percentage of attendees and it's
measured in basis points that convert to
orbit to paid organizers and what that
meant is that as we optimize towards
that metric
we saw more and more customers coming
from that segment and we didn't have to
spend marketing dollars we didn't have
to spend sales dollars against that so
if you pit us from an efficiency
standpoint against a traditional
ticketing company that's 100 sales
against Eventbrite where the vast
majority of your sellers your event
organizers are self-service are finding
the site on their own and converting
that's
um you're always going to win that game
your cost of acquisition go to zero are
effectively zero we can take that that
investment money that we would have
spent on sales and invested into uh into
building engineering innovating more on
the product offering outstanding
customer service and and that's the
that's a notion of efficiency to really
cling on to
at Eventbrite we have this sort of
unofficial internal model motto of
Relentless Evolution because we believe
that complacency is death uh and so when
you think about Eventbrite the model we
set out to originally enable anybody to
be able to create a live experience and
sell tickets so we were an organizer
tool set
um as we built our platform we
understood that we could actually create
an open platform that was self-service
that anybody could use and we could also
open up an API that would allow
thousands of developers to build Niche
features and services that we simply
weren't going to build because we are a
one-size-fits-all solution and so we
really focused on driving organizers to
this platform to understand how they
could use Eventbrite for ease of use and
to sell more tickets by promoting their
event
and then something really interesting
started to happen last year we had 1.1
million actively attended events on the
platform Now Kevin mentioned our free
service two-thirds of those are free out
of that one-third of paid events we
generated four organizers one 1.1
billion dollars in Gross ticket sales
I'm not giving you those big numbers to
impress you because you don't look very
impressed but I uh but I'm telling you
that what we what we realized was that
we had built something that was scaling
and it was Global we ticketed events in
over 190 countries last year
we could still continue along our way
and build this ticketing platform and
keep keep grabbing market share and
moving into new territories and we're
learning how to scale our service even
more efficiently than before
what's really interesting is that about
two million people a week buy tickets on
Eventbrite and over half of them are
repeat buyers
when we survey those repeat buyers
they don't know that they've used
Eventbrite so we have a true opportunity
there not only do we have an opportunity
to extend our brand to Consumers we
truly have an opportunity to create a
global Marketplace for live experiences
and so when you think about the Adaptive
qualities you have to have as a startup
there truly is no greater satisfaction
as an entrepreneur than to disrupt
yourself
and I think right now this very day uh
you know our team of 450 breitlings
throughout eight worldwide offices are
stretching themselves to imagine a
future where we are the de facto place
that you come to find live experiences
we have to become a consumer Habit to
really achieve this idea of the
marketplace and to really nail this idea
of liquidity and that's so exciting to
us and we could again be just building
this ticket This Global ticketing
platform and eventually move up to the
head and try to go after Ticketmaster
once and for all we've identified this
opportunity that's just too great to
pass up
and so I think about the the sort of
pain that we're about to feel as we
morph into this idea of the marketplace
and we go after something that's so
right in front of us but uh entirely
difficult to nail we think about
marketplaces like Amazon as an
inspiration
um and I I'm I'm grateful that we have
the team that is willing to be brave
enough to be adaptive because again
complacency is death and we're in
pursuit of Relentless evolution
we just wanted to put a white-haired
monkey up here
so we Julia talked about uh the the
Adaptive qualities of our startup
organism and we talked about our shift
in movement into the consumer side and
that's an enormous bet another one by
the way that we always should mention is
that you've all witnessed over the last
few years is the movement to mobile it
was something internally that uh that
everyone at Eventbrite uh realized and
we just said let's sit down and let's
spend x amount of time and move
everything over to the responsive web to
the native apps and it's that type of
again adaptation you know I think in
that more Universal example uh that
companies need to go through otherwise
if you look back again and maybe my
George III history lessons do pay off
you look at these repeating uh
repetitions of History you have brick
and mortar retails being disrupted by
the internet in the same manner now we
see traditional web companies being
disrupted by mobile so that adaptive
nature is just absolutely key
but differentiated is uh you know first
and foremost a lot of what we think
about in in terms of beating the
competitors you don't uh if you've read
Peter's Teal's book
um you've you've read about you don't
want to be an undifferentiated airline
you want to have
this competitive sustainable Advantage
I'll mention a couple about event rights
and and one is that the service is
self-service and and that sounds
um like a duh kind of moment but when
you're moving billions of dollars in
small amounts all around the world
it's actually just a real honey pot for
uh for hackers for
um fraudsters and so on and so we've
continually Been Under Fire from
fraudsters and as a result over the
years we've built a fraud detection and
deterrence team that that
um in the engineering and operations
around that we consider very proprietary
and you give us Advantage when we see
new competitors entering the space or
trying to gain any kind of scale
fraud really acts as is almost say a air
cushion of sorts you we've we've
effectively deterred fraudsters from our
site and they swarm over to a
competitive site or a like site and and
overrun that and that's from the kind of
algorithm side and also the operations
side of creating a silver bullet to stop
the bad guys but not stop your customers
in a self-service manner so that is is
you know a kind of specific example of
differentiation the other that we
alluded to that Julia will speak to is
Just Around Talent and thinking around
Talent as a differentiation sure so
um in 2009 when we raised our six and a
half million from Sequoia Capital we
were at a stage in the company where we
knew exactly where we wanted to go and
who we needed to get us there and the
Plan called for us to grow our team of
30 to 100 in less than a year at the
same time we are watching all of our
sort of uh fellow Tech entrepreneurs go
through their own hyper growth stories
and come out the other end with uh
broken cultures the loss of identity and
they really had to go back and
self-correct on some of the hiring
mistakes they'd made or they've kind of
lost their way in terms of the soul of
their company so the idea of growing
from 30 to 100 terrified me and at the
same time I felt this irrational love
and loyalty towards the company not
unlike what I feel for our own children
to be honest so I put all of that
together and realized that the only way
that we were going to go through this
hyper growth State and grow our team
successfully was if
somebody and preferably a crazy person
like myself but basically any founder
and you have a little bit of crazy
um
would be focused entirely on people and
I think what I realized about myself is
that you know through this journey of
being an entrepreneur and trying to
blend my background with with you know
in television with this this newfound
reality as an operator of my own company
I realized that I had a keen sense of
how I wanted to make people feel
and so I dug into that and took a leap
of faith and said um to Kevin and
Renault I'd like to focus entirely on
people and specifically the breitlings
we had built up our customer service
operation and our marketing operations
so we understood how to try to find
people and how to service them and
really what that meant to to the
Eventbrite experience but we hadn't
thought about how we were going to scale
our team and what we hoped our culture
would be
and one of the things that I think
differentiates us from other tech
companies
um is the idea that our culture is
designed to be sustainable so it's it's
actually a manifestation of every single
Breitling who is currently at the
company
we have the free meals we have massage
Mondays we have the cool office those
are just table Stakes these days in
startup world it's actually about how
you treat people and how you make them
feel that makes all the difference in
the world so what I'm most proud of is
not how cool our company is it's that I
know I work at a company where we'll
always do the right thing and where
we're truly people-centric and that
actually means that we put people before
the company and the company before
ourselves
and that in practice isn't always the
easiest way to operate and we get into
some really interesting debates we do
things the hard way we uh sort of take
windy paths to things things are not
always clean and streamlined and
sometimes messy but ultimately the
fabric of our culture and who we are as
a team is actually is is what is going
to lead us to success it is what is
going to give us the opportunity to be
an independent Standalone company from
the Long Haul
so
we did a lot of talking I hope you guys
gleaned a little bit from us about the
early days of Eventbrite the startup
environment that we've observed as well
as the three traits that we think are
optimal towards the startup organism but
now we want you guys to let us have it
we want your your hardest uh most
awkward questions or not
do you mind if I start before we go into
the audience can I ask a couple quick
questions just because I know these are
questions that might be on people's
minds
um and first of all thank you that was
fantastic I get now how eventbrite's
really the unique love child of all of
you of the experiences that both of you
brought to the table and it adds a lot
more color to me I wanted just to first
ask a question about being a married
couple as a co-founding team and just go
deeper on to that
um
is it more is it more easier more
difficult to have honest work
conversations with someone when you know
that you're going to be going home with
them at night
well yeah I think you answered that it's
very simple I mean backing up uh when
when as we're married we have to be very
uh cautious and aware of the Rules of
Engagement uh because you don't just
create a feud with a co-founder you
disrupt a wonderful relationship so uh
you know and we as we reflect back we
really found and we really thought about
how we're complementary and expertise
and Julia is passionate about uh really
bringing on and retaining Talent as a
core aspect of the business and then
whatever I do uh becomes you know very
complementary and so a key to it is not
to to overlap but the other side of it
is that uh there just has to be a truth
in in directness it's something we're
always working on but I I'm I'm proud of
the fact where you got through a whole
uh presentation together with
without talking over one another or
anything I think it's also about clearly
defining your roles and dividing and
conquering as Kevin mentioned we were
given that advice by um dear friends of
ours Michael and Sochi Birch who have
co-founded many companies together
including bibo
um and we took that to heart that's our
that's like our motto we have really
very few times broken that Golden Rule
and there's a reason why that rules in
place but it also allows you to get from
point A to point B two times faster so
when you're a co-founding team of three
you shouldn't be overlapping and
hopefully you have complimentary skills
and so I think it applies to all
co-founderships I'd say that
um one Nuance I'll point out and
hopefully it's obvious is that we have
one CEO and we're really lucky that
Kevin's our CEO he truly is my mentor
but I think it's really important as you
grow your team to have clearly defined
roles of leadership and while we
cooperate the company with many other
people on our executive staff Kevin is
our CEO and so I I never obviously Julia
embodies uh higher P or work with people
that are smarter than you are so yeah
exactly so I think that for us it's it's
worked out
I'm not really sure where that went but
you were I think did I say that in
Reverse yeah the best uh
there's so many asides and it's like
it's being recorded
um so
we'll talk about it at home yeah we'll
talk about it okay okay fair enough fair
enough that's great I know there's a
bunch of questions we'll open it up and
I'll let you guys drive let's start in
the front right here should we put that
really in the beginning of November
right you guys tried to service all
outdoor events but did you ever have a
very narrow Beach Head Market or were
you always out of the emergency good job
well the the tech uh bloggers that were
started to hold conferences was really
that that beach head uh and and that was
interesting that was that
um it wasn't as defined as we've seen
some of you know the case study of tech
history of uh of documentum in crossing
the chasm and so on but it was a
beachhead and and it did follow a
pattern that there was
um that these media companies were
making a good you know decent living off
advertising but then starting to hold
these conferences and so on really
supplemented it but what's Magic about
what what has been really magical about
the market we're in is that it is truly
horizontal and what we hear from the
sort of would-be competitors and
different players in different spaces is
oh if you're in if you're going to
service bands if you're going to be in
the music space you can't be in the
endurance running space or if you're in
the conference space you can't be in the
politics space and in fact we've we've
shown that this can be a wonderful
horizontal platform and that's magical
when you when you can cross all these
different categories but that initial
beachhead was attacked and I and don't
do what we you know don't do as as we
did really do spend a little more time
focusing on the beach head we were all
over the place early on
sure so I had no idea what I was doing
uh let's start from that point um so
when I I think that I've approached
approached everything quite earnestly
and objectively
um and I did some sort of soul searching
around what kind of culture we wanted to
create and what kind of culture we had
at a team of 30. uh we were doing our
first branding exercise at the same time
as I was doing the soul searching and we
asked our customers to define or use
words to describe Eventbrite the service
and they came back with words like
accessible genuine delightful Innovative
empowering when I looked at that list I
realized it actually described the team
of 30 and that how cool that was that
the two were intrinsically linked the
people should reflect the product and
vice versa so instead of Reinventing the
wheel and trying to come up with like
core values or a mission statement or
just ripping off Zappos I I really kind
of defined our culture tenets around
that and we use that list to start
hiring so we looked for skills and
impact this list of culture tenants and
then this the sort of fourth thing that
I had identified in our group which
basically we call it the make it happen
Spirit but I'll Define it in an easier
way it's grit so it's really that
ability to to stretch far enough to make
something happen and to give back to
your community
whether it be your team our product our
company or the customers so that's kind
of where I started and I realized that I
wanted to create a sustainable culture
and it dawned on me really early on that
incred in order to create a sustainable
culture the culture could not be defined
by one person or one group of people had
to be defined by everybody and so a lot
of that first year was just me sitting
back and observing and then finding
moments where I could provide a resource
or a Tailwind or encouragement to
somebody who was giving back to our
culture and that's how we started to
create that sustainability because if
you think about
culture like the word is just beaten to
death I mean overused and I don't even
know what it means anymore but if you
think about culture it keeps you
centered it should be that centering
Force for the company for the team so no
matter how good things get and no matter
how bad things get
ultimately if you create a sustainable
culture you should be able to stay in
that Center place right and so as we've
created this sustainable culture that's
really a manifestation of every single
Breitling good or bad we make hiring
mistakes we see it in our culture I want
that to happen I want that mirror to
happen we really are building this Bank
of trust and so I think I I value the
bank of trust when we have to debit from
it uh and deliver bad news we quickly
credit it
um but you know I think it's all about
that Center place and that trust and
sustainability and so it's a work in
progress uh somebody mentioned uh you
know oh one day we should write a book
about our culture and I really hope that
doesn't happen because I never want this
to be over I never want it to be in a
place where I've I've clearly figured it
out because I love to to keep learning
and I think that we're a work in
progress
how about right up here hi thanks
um I don't know if this question would
be too rude to us but I'm really curious
to find out because as Eventbrite is
scaling you'll be working with more
events right so how do you actually
ensure the security of this event that
you work with just to give an example
because recently a group of friends and
I actually could start in a hackathon so
even right and then just one day before
the hackathon we actually received an
email to say that oh this um hackathon
is not it's a false alarm it's actually
a birthday surprise that he organized
for the friend yeah so as I'm just
wondering you know how are you guys
gonna answer such issues but it's I mean
it's a very challenging problem it's uh
you know we're a Marketplace business of
buyers and sellers and we're
facilitating uh that that connection and
so we have to kind of look at the signal
and the noise we have to look we have to
continue to build out our trust and
safety uh team and we look for uh
anomalies uh that that don't match the
patterns of tip local events in both
from a host side or organizer side and
an attendee side so it's it's trying to
solve that with technology and and
people but it's uh extremely challenging
aspect of the business yeah it's it's a
virtual good but a a real experience
which is a very different uh problem to
solve than a than a physical good did
you go to the birthday party no sorry
uh
how about right here in the front uh can
you talk about the SD referral program
and its role in your growth sure the
attendee to organizer the conversion
that virtuous cycle is that what you're
asking yeah
um
we met with Jeff Jordan do you remember
this uh way back when in like 2008 or
2009 and remember Jeff said he was
former senior executive at paypalanese
now at Andreessen Horowitz yeah and and
we were talking about OpenTable right
yeah yeah so um he was telling us about
this virtuous cycle that OpenTable has
and we were sort of salivating over it
and realizing that there were these
distinct parallels between our
businesses and I remember wishing that
we had such a virtual cycle where we
could turn our buyers into Sellers and
that actually started to happen
organically and maybe not so organically
maybe that was really the the inflection
point for us and we started to tune our
service to that but what we found were
the
um you know we have tens of Millions
millions of attendees and just a very
small percentage of them not even one
percent of them convert into
paid organizers and they become they
become organizers and so to really fuel
that growth takes a lot of iteration and
a lot of sort of uh tinkering behind the
scenes but it is so powerful if you
think of in mass that the tens of
millions of consumers that we can
convert into sellers that it actually
has become the the number one driver of
paid organizers for us and is a huge
flywheel of growth for us I think when
we tapped into that that was one of the
the sort of biggest discoveries and
biggest accelerates for our for our
success when we were able to identify
that it's that that observational piece
is an effector as a startup entrepreneur
entrepreneurs you're conducting
experiments and you're looking to see
where it takes
um what patterns emerge we saw very
early on that in 2006 that SEO was a big
driver of the business uh we learned you
know we took a page from Jeremy
stoppelman in Yelp and the work they
were doing there and optimize towards
SEO and then we saw
um you know somewhat surprisingly around
that time as well this growth of
Facebook traffic to our site and when
you see that happening organically you
try to understand that behavior and dig
it and accelerate it and what it was in
that case it was uh people sharing in in
their news feed and with their friends
what they were doing and it was a very
natural action and then you accelerated
a PayPal lesson there is the is Paypal
really drafted off eBay at first it was
merchants on eBay started to integrate
PayPal and it wasn't a proactive program
of PayPal they saw it happening
organically and they built features
towards that and it took off so really
as an entrepreneur you want to find
those vectors of growth retention
different drivers of the business and
and oftentimes when you conduct all
these different experiments they'll come
to you